i want to very quickly look at this very
strange interview we we i didn't see
this until yesterday we covered oh sorry
i hit my microphone there we covered
this trump rally that took place in
florence arizona uh over the weekend we
covered the rally itself and we talked
about it earlier this week on the show
but there was this interview done by
newsmax of trump
um seemingly at the rally
and um it is of course trump's visibly
sweaty and disheveled his shirt's so but
you know the guy's just a mess
but it is very clear that trump is on a
war path on a war footing we might say
against mitch mcconnell and sort of what
he sees as the establishment republican
party not very favorable to him let's
look at some of these clips this is a
very interesting interview here trump
addressing fauci and his handling of the
pandemic we heard some lock him up
chance for dr fauci out there what about
holding dr fauci accountable well he is
accountable he's
somebody that has done some pretty poor
work you know with me he wanted to keep
it open to china keep it open to europe
we would have lost hundreds of thousands
more people now it's important to
remember that even you know some of
these things may be true by chance
because trump sometimes might like sort
of casually tell the truth by mere
probability
but you know the whole thing about fauci
wanted to keep it open there was a brief
period during which fauci was saying mr
president sir i'm unsure
whether stopping flights is really going
to contain this and and fauci was sort
of right i mean you know so even every
single one of these statements could
really be looked at in more detail and
they're they're really not truths
but he wasn't a big factor in my
administration but biden has made him a
big factor and
they have done a horrible job on covet
or the china virus as i call it but
they've done a horrible job what would
you be doing differently right now when
it comes to covet it's actually a good
question that's a good question from
newsmax well one thing no mandates the
mandates are killing our economy i'm
convinced that when you have supply
chain problems you can't get paper you
can't get lumber they can't build houses
they have no nails they have nothing
and i think
to start off with the mandates there is
no evidence at all that vaccine
requirements at businesses are what is
causing supply chain issues there's just
no evidence of that disaster and people
just aren't working you can't get people
to work because of the mandate so that
would be the first thing i do because
almost a non-factor as you as many of
you know
we have seen that mandates ultimately
lead to you know like at most half of
one or one percent
um
staff loss and there are many
places where it's zero because
everybody's obviously vaccinated any you
know there's just no evidence for what
trump is saying
um trump also asked about the situation
at the border which is interesting
because quite frankly very little has
changed at the border under joe biden
we've got a charged up crowd out there
and they're very excited to see you very
excited to see carrie lake this is going
to be an important state in 2022 what do
you think is the most important election
issue
for the voters of 2022 in arizona i
think the borders for arizona certainly
are and that you know the whole country
is a border if you think about it you
know they're pouring throughout the
country but not really for arizona and
texas in particular the borders are
a terrible terrible problem we have
millions of people coming into our
country now understand that there has
been no
major change to the dynamics at the
border in terms of people coming in
other than
there was a period in
2020 due to the pandemic
where movement in general was down and
so
you combine the seasonality of border
crossings with the pandemic there was a
lull
and then it resumed and it started
resuming in december of 2020 and january
of 2021 even when donald trump was still
president continued under biden so
there's the seasonality aspect and the
pandemic aspect but there's not been
this
according to the right and people like
trump the day biden took office
everything changed at the border and it
was like wide open come on in and it's
just not true
you know many are coming from prisons of
other countries over 129 countries they
said last week that people from 120
countries it's not just like mexico and
honduras and you know et cetera it's
they had 129 countries so trump's still
very confused about everything but as
well as uh immigration and then this is
where it gets very interesting trump
going right in on mitch mcconnell this
is clearly a battle that trump is not
going to give up on and this is going to
be interesting to watch throughout 2022.
when it comes to the leadership of the
gop right now what kind of letter grade
would you give them
speaker senator leader mccarthy and
mcconnell well i've been working well
with kevin and we've been doing very
well together and we're working on the
election and i'd give him a very high
mark now what that means is mccarthy has
mostly remained loyal to me
in my insane claims that i really won
the election that's what trump means by
that
i'm not a fan of mcconnell i haven't
been i helped him get elected without me
he would have lost his race
and then he goes and makes stupid
statements after january 6 which and
what that means is mcconnell has not
remained blindly loyal to me to the same
degree as i would like to see was not my
situation this was a just a stupid thing
he did but he's a bad leader he gave
them two months a two-month stay that
two months of of adjustment gave them
a power that they should have never had
so i'm not a fan of him and i think he's
hurting the party very badly so that is
absolutely fascinating and it is really
clear guys
that the
trump mcconnell battle is not going to
subside anytime soon
now whether mcconnell cares i don't know
i don't know how much longer mitch
mcconnell wants to be a senator i don't
know how much he cares
but as we get into 2022 with trump
endorsing people
and the republican party of which the
senate is a big piece deciding how they
want to
um direct resources and effort
uh including financial and public
relations uh resources
this mcconnell versus trump thing could
get very very interesting my interest in
it is very it's it's it's
it's self-centered quite frankly it's
selfish i want there to be as much chaos
between the trump and the mcconnell
wings of the republican party as
possible with the hope that it'll mess
them up and with the hope that it will
make it difficult for them
to do well in november that's my
priority let me know your thoughts on
that you can find me on twitter at
dpakman we'll take a break and what a
program we have for you today
one of our sponsors is real paper our
forests on earth remove about a quarter
of the carbon that humans put into the
atmosphere and yet every day we're
cutting down tens of thousands of trees
to make single use paper products real
paper is fighting back real paper makes
paper products that are truly
sustainable their paper towels and
toilet paper are 100 percent plastic
free made without any virgin tree fibers
meaning no new trees are cut down but
real paper is super soft and durable you
don't have to sacrifice quality to help
the planet these are great products from
a usability standpoint i'm using real
paper at home you can do a one-time
purchase they also have easy
subscriptions all orders ship in 100
recyclable plastic free packaging
everybody needs paper towels and toilet
paper buy ones that you will feel good
about and they're giving my audience
thirty percent off a subscription when
you go to
realpaper.compacman and use the code
pacman the link is down below